[Music]
hi i'm jen wilson senior programmer and
welcome to this film independent
presents screening of montana story
a special thanks to our lead sponsor the
hollywood foreign press association and
vision media who hosts all of our
virtual screenings and q and a's and now
please welcome today's q a guests
writers and directors of montana story
scott mcgee and david siegel
[Music]
aaron
i just want to see him one more time
seven years ago she ran away
from him
how is it that i'm feeling pity for him
right now i think i should go you just
got here no no this is better stay the
night at least
is there something wrong with mr t
we're gonna put him down
i'm not gonna let you kill him
are you planning on keeping an old horse
in the big apple what you think i'm
being stupid of course not i've done way
stupider things for animals than drag a
horse from montana to new york won't you
release
me
welcome hi jim thank you jen so uh
because uh foam independent is a member
organization for a lot of aspiring
filmmakers
i usually start with a question of um
what your origin story is so
for each of you could you talk about how
you got into writing and directing
uh we could start with david
sure
they're kind of the same story
our origin story is sort of intertwined
in that
excuse me
um neither one of us went to film school
i was doing an mfa at risd i was an
artist and scott was gonna be an
academic he was doing a phd in japanese
film studies at berkeley
we know each other through scott's
sister kelly who's done production
design on all of our work and i met
kelly at the
at the art institute in san francisco
before i went to risd
and scott and i got to talking about
movies a lot and things that he was
interested in and
when i finished my mfa and he had
finished his m.a we decided to make some
short films together and see how that
went
and it just kind of grew from there and
i i think that's why we
write produce and direct together
because there was no one there we were
so ignorant of the way things were that
we just
we just started doing it together and it
worked really well for us and we
actually moved into the same apartment
became roommates
got jobs like parallel jobs as waiters
and just kind of like taught ourselves
to make short films on 16 millimeter
just from the ground up knowing nothing
yeah and you know that i i want to give
a shout out to
the film arts foundation in san
francisco because that's where we were
based and i think it without fulfillment
phil marsh foundation was like
you know like the the school locker for
us because we
we could go there and use their
resources and they were so helpful
in uh in kind of just guiding us
technically about connecting us with an
independent film community there it was
a really nice
i'm always fascinated by creative teams
uh how does that work when you get when
you actually get on the set do you
divide up
um directing duties
um
how does it work yeah we
i mean we write together so that's the
kind of foundation of our you know
creative process i would say it's like
we really you know kind of hash out
ideas together and you know and a lot of
that writing is very visual because we
know we're going to be directing it so
by the time we get to set
um
and we also rehearse the actors together
so there's a whole kind of conversation
a kind of creative collaborative
conversation with the actors and all of
our keys before we ever get to see
all other aspects of prep you know are
done completely together but but on set
we have a kind of different like over
the years i think it's become more and
more so we have kind of different of
domains maybe and david tends to be the
person
who's right there talking to actors
after a take is over and communicating
more directly and i've kind of learned
my best role is to kind of communicate
with david and that way there's sort of
one
voice coming out of our head
if that makes sense
it's very you know after so many years
it's you know
our communication it's very fluid and
often you know non-verbal so
we uh
it's able to work that way
and but but i think it's helpful like
we both
can answer a question on set like
it's easy to find us because there are
two of them
okay
um so let's talk about montana story
which was in uh toronto film festival
2021 right
that's right um
what inspired you to write a story about
characters in montana did you do either
one of you have a connection to montana
we we we have
almost no connection
we were about to go into prep on an
adaptation of a book called the friend
um by sigrid nunez which which is what
we're actually trying to make now
and when the pandemic hit and it got
shut down like everything else and we
kept thinking um i think like a lot of
people did that you know things were
going to come back to normal
um sooner than they did or happy and so
we kept thinking that the friend was
going to be able to be made in 2020 and
by the beginning of the summer i think
we were june we realized that that
wasn't going to happen and
you know i think
what was going on in the world
really kind of pushed us towards writing
a new script
and
we were kind of determined to try and
find a way to make it with a small cast
and crew in a place where the virus
wasn't so
heavy and at that time montana was that
yeah i mean this was still you know the
middle of the lockdown in new york and
you know we weren't working in the same
spaces we were communicating via phone
calls and zoom from our you know i live
in chinatown david was here so it was a
little it was a little crazy that way
but it was it wound up being really
productive i mean we spent you know
eight or ten hours a day on the on the
phone with each other you know on
speakerphone sort of another guy who
works with us mike spreeder helped us
through that process kind of and it was
really great the three of us kind of on
you know in our he's he's in brooklyn
i'm in chinatown davidson flatiron and
we were just kind of brewing up a story
that was somewhere outside of where any
of us were and yeah montana
we it really just seemed like where we
wanted to
imagine a story weirdly
i mean i think it came from i mean scott
and i both grew up in california and
stuff spent a lot of time in the central
valley and sierra nevada mountains and
um i think
other ideas that we had about stories in
california in the west
um sort of laid the foundation of some
of what we wound up talking about for
montana's story
but we had not as scott said we'd never
been to montana so we were it was a kind
of a montana of our imagination and and
the internet
before we actually got there and
it you know of course exceeded our
expectations
and uh and and
it's a beautiful beautiful place
i really like the way
your your script was laid out
so that it
allows the audience to discover
uh things uh in you know like in real
time you don't know anything beforehand
so
when uh you know owen t who plays one of
your two main characters gets there
you don't know if it's his house
you don't know why he's there
and you find out someone's in it you
know what i mean like it all happens
it's like
and i found it it drew me in so much
uh you know when the sister gets there
it's like well what happened between the
two of them like obviously something's
going on something's wrong and this felt
just kind of like a mystery
um unfolding and i loved the way he told
the story like that the other part is
that you have a character who's there
but not their wade who's in a coma the
whole time their dad is in a coma
and
we can only know about him through the
other characters
when when you are writing something like
that how are you thinking about it
revealing wade through the other
characters
i mean what you've just been saying i
mean thank you for for saying all that
because that's really what was on our
mind is like how to
you know
parcel out the information in a way that
would not be frustrating and not be
boring what would you know kind of like
draw people in
and
make the audience really yeah but really
make the audience our partners in
uncovering the story kind of that was
kind of what we talked about how do we
you know
make that a fun uh
make each revelation kind of a fun thing
to experience as as a
watcher of the story
you know the what you're saying about
wade
you can imagine that as we were writing
you know we thought should we do should
there be a flashback of some kind should
we see
the you know the inciting incident sort
of you know from seven years ago and it
just continued to feel to us like it
kind of a flashback would sort of
violate
some of what you're talking about in
terms of the way the story
unfolds and like the way the audience
comes to understand what happened
and we really felt like well that should
happen between cal and aaron like when
they finally do when they finally are
able to communicate that's where we
should really sort of feel it
yeah i was i was really glad that you
actually didn't have a flashback because
every single moment he's mentioned i
created him for myself
and you know he obviously came across
different
to each one of those characters
but you know when they go and they visit
the mine and you reveal
the part of the conflict between the
daughter and the father about
his
unscrupulous transactions regarding
mining that land
um
he just appeared for me
um
i did i actually i was glad that that
your
his nurse says at one point that he
won't wake up because i did wonder if
that was gonna be part of the story
he was gonna miraculously wake up and
it's like okay that's cleared up he's
not gonna
like
like show up and redeem himself
um
talk about um casting your two actors uh
haley lou richardson and and owen teague
who are absolutely terrific in this
thank you
we had a really great time with both of
them we really did
and so sort of in line with what you're
talking about the way the story unfolds
it's it it puts a lot of burden on the
actors because the actors you know they
really have to carry
the exposition they have to be able to
give the audience the feeling and the
kind of emotional state um that
you know we that that were the height of
it that that we wanted to achieve and
and we really you know we were just sort
of knocked out by both of them but we
had been talking to haley about playing
a part in the friend so we had gotten to
know her a little bit over zoom
and owen audition we had heard about him
and
weren't that familiar with his work and
then he auditioned for his audition was
beautiful
and uh and everything had to happen so
quickly
by the time we finished writing the
script in order to beat the winter which
we didn't entirely need but to get to
montana and shoot the movie so we had to
make foot casting decisions and we knew
we wanted haley and uh and we just loved
owen and that's how it came there was a
real leap of faith though with owen in
particular because we
i mean he was
you know in his own lockdown in florida
and his parents like like he you know he
put himself on tape in his parents attic
you know and which you know is the way
things go now but we'd never cast a
movie that way where we just okay we're
gonna
meet him for the first time like in
montana
and and you know just seeing the two of
them together for the first time we had
no idea what they would feel like as a
pair of people you know like yeah
you know and it was
exciting that way but it was really you
know kind of scary i mean we really
wondered about their chemistry because
you know it needed to be familial like
they needed to feel like a brother and a
sister
and they just walked right into that in
montana when they got there and that was
that was really nice to see
they're both really terrific and i've
really enjoyed discovering them over the
years
i actually did
i used to program for la film festival
and we sh we showed
haley lou's first two features in the
same year
and so uh i did q a with her
and it's so interesting to see her
when she's in serious roles because i
know in person she's like a bright light
of cheeriness and happiness so uh it's
it's so interesting to see you know when
she does very like contain and ground it
you know like she did in columbus and
like she doesn't in your movies but
she's fantastic i feel like both she and
owen are those like from the inside out
actors you know they can contain this
universe like within them and then sort
of like open
for you and um i just thought they
carried the movie so well
it's not easy to do
um
so for your characters
um
the characters you know um of the
housekeeper and her son
and the
the um the nurse that's taking care of
the dad
um are all people of color the the
the people that take care of the of the
house who grew up with this family
are native americans and then the nurse
is uh kenyan
from africa
were did you in particular want to
say something about the people of color
versus the white people in the film i
know native people are a huge part of
montana's story would be hard to make a
movie without native characters in it
there that would seem truthful
um do you want to talk about that
juxtaposition
sure yeah i mean
that that was really something that you
know we dove into montana and kind of
really started getting to know it as a
place
and the native characters really did
come out of that exploration as just
learning the history of the land and
learning who lives there and and
all of that it it did it was a very kind
of natural evolution to um you know kind
of
discover those characters in our story
in an interesting way we we
we thought a lot about place and home um
and how it
how people define that for themselves
and how people feel proprietary about
that
the way people are
like either rooted or not rooted in a
particular place
and
we felt like you know the the characters
around
cal and aaron
needed to have a stake in
that sense of place and home
in a way that was deeper than um what
what
was going on for cala and aaron and that
when we resolve the story
we come back to something that feels
like um
it has some sort of
uh
duration or longevity that
i don't know transcends
the specifics of the story itself
it's interesting
oh sorry go ahead i was wondering if
that yeah that makes sense i think that
makes sense
yeah
it's interesting you know um
i
when when there are people of color in a
movie now you sort of expect that
there's going to be a conflict that
involves there being people of color in
it so
uh i was interested in in how this
relationship
with them would unfold but i ended what
i ended up feeling
was that
they're very connected
but it's a bit of an uneasy connection
and
um
i don't but but it it it led to
what i felt was the deeper meaning of
the story which i don't know if you two
feel this but especially in the last few
years in this
country you know people have started to
really think that it's going to take a
whole generation of people leaving this
earth before we can really change a lot
of things because those people are
holding things in place
and that's what it sort of felt like
you needed this this older white
patriarch with all of his old
patriarchal beliefs
about
montana and how to do business in the
world you needed for him to pass before
everybody else could start to change
uh into something else and that included
his kids and
the other characters as well
did you feel that way about it too i
think that's really you've articulated
it really really well and you know we
when we were talking
more from the inside of the story
the cal does what he does to his father
at the end of the story because that's
what needs to happen in order for a
transition to occur
and um i like the way you
map that on that idea on to the whole
story itself because that is something
that we were thinking about and um
and i think you put it really well we we
went off to montana i was just thinking
off to montana um
you know we wrote this script faster
than anything we've ever written it was
like a matter of weeks from the time we
first started kicking off like ideas for
it to the time we were actually in
montana shooting
um which
never we've never experienced that
before like working so quickly to
beat the winter really but also just to
get out there and do something because
we were so you know kind of locked down
in new york
but um we
got to montana and we hadn't ever found
a title for the story it was it was on
the front page of the script it was
called untitled montana story because
that's
that's what it had been the whole time
we were working on it
and it wasn't until we were editing that
we realized that the title for the movie
really was montana's story um that that
title really
felt good to us and part of the reason
it felt so good i think is because it in
a strange way it became a story about
place about what it means to call a
place home and you know be in a place or
from a place or leave a place and and um
and
and what a place is now versus what a
place can be
yeah
yeah i i really felt that with the
characters uh
the way that it was established that it
was their home but also
didn't feel like they're home do you
know what i mean like they didn't feel
you could tell that it used to be their
home but they didn't feel
comfy there like a home is supposed to
feel right
um
so talk about the last scene uh
it's so good it's so gorgeous the last
scene of the movie um
was that something that you had always
envisioned was that always going to be
the end or was that something that you
came up with
uh later on or
you know i
this is gonna sound like maybe it's not
true but i'm just i'm just saying it
because it is true
there were so many things about what we
scripted that fell
exactly into place in the places that we
were looking for
in montana like the ranch itself the way
we had plotted out the movements
around the ranch and in the ranch house
and we did script that's that
that
um in a way that we were pretty
confident we would never be able to
realize and
and we were able to find a
place that
um played really well for the
reservation and we were able to find a
place that you know that we could create
a corral like that and the horses and um
we went out there with the horses it was
the end of a day we went out there with
a drone like you know tiny little camera
on this little
thing and a guy a local guy flying it
who you know had some experience but he
wasn't like a hollywood like drone
operator and we went out we had one good
take of that final shot and it's the
take that's in the movie like everything
else was chaos the horses were going the
wrong way the wind was taking the drone
out of you know we nearly hit some power
lines and it was you know nuts but there
was one
beautiful beautiful day was the very
first time as the one that got it and um
it's just what we had scripted that's
what we'd imagine and we could we
probably like like the movie really
needs to end with that kind of
sweep
but you know we have very limited
resources to make movie and very limited
time and and so i have to say the other
thing that that i love watching in that
final scene is the chemistry between
you know joey and mookie those those two
guys who play the role at us
i mean they they set this they they set
the scene for that shot like you know
without without that yeah
they just both feel so comfortable in
their skin and so comfortable to be
there and just they really kind of
anchor the feeling at the end of the
movie for me really yeah
it feels you know it he it feels huge in
the end like
you know whatever happens
i mean basically it becomes you know
whatever happens to mr t sort of like
sets the tone for
what is going to happen to these people
you know what's their decision about
what's going to happen to mr t feels
like who's who they are and who they're
going to be in the future so it feels
huge by the time you get to that point
and um
i think i just felt i i was like
i didn't envision them giving the horse
to someone and i was like why like i was
in i was in you know owens narrow vision
of what what has to happen with this
horse like what are the options of what
can happen to this horse and then by the
time they finally decide what to do with
that was like i didn't even think of
that
like
like yeah they're in montana just give
the horse to somebody with a big ass
ranch
[Laughter]
but it makes so much sense and i and and
it's just like oh yeah this feels like
the right decision thank god
it felt like a weight off
um
so uh
the movie comes out this week right in
theaters
next week next friday may 13th okay
yeah and it's opening wider the week uh
though two weeks after the 20th and then
the 27th it's opening in a lot of places
well thank you for coming and talking
about it it's such a it was such a
wonderful film to experience and um
i just love the way that
you know it is its own
specific story in a specific time period
but resonates so deeply on so many
larger issues issues about the
environment issues about
um
[Music]
our relationships with people of color
and
i just thought it was a really beautiful
project and i congratulate you um
i'm excited excited for your opening are
you excited
i'm excited yeah anxious and excited and
it was such a beautiful and i'm like i
transformational experience for us
actually going out there and making that
and uh
so we hope we're
happy to hear that it resonated that way
for you and i hope it does for other
people as well
all right thanks a lot it's been a
pleasure talking